hey guys adam welcome back to the layah
Heilpern show powered by icon plus so as always
it is powered by openplus a really quick news
announcement for you so iconfi has surpassed 25
million dollars in capital commitment so they're
really looking forward to the launch of the very
first all-in-one digital asset platform built on
icon and the release is actually coming um on in
january 2021 so stay tuned for that that will
be great i want to say thank you as well to my
sponsors block buy so i actually use them to earn
up to eight point six percent interest on my usdc
so ufcc is a stable coin it's pegged to the us
dollar um and you can get up to 8.6 interest and
if you think about everything that's going on this
year um interest rates are practically negative
actually in in europe they pretty much are um
so i think the bank of england is like 0.01 so
that's pretty insane so i'll leave the link for
that if you guys are interested um and before i
bring in my brilliant guest um i want to say a
quick thank you to coin phillips so um they are
doing some incredible work across the states to
push bitcoin mass adoption they have now 1 200 um
bitcoin atms providing access to everyday people
um so again i'm going to leave a discount code for
you you can get um i think it's about 10 off um
transaction fees so that would be great so joining
me today we have a pretty interesting topic um
i guess it's kind of like politics meets bitcoin
two of my favorite kind of things put together so
joining me today is isaiah jackson the author of
bitcoin and black america and the co-host of the
gentleman of crypto let's bring him in how are
you doing doing great oh man glad to be here glad
to be talking with you absolutely yeah i'm super
excited to talk to you because you have like i
said two of my most obsessed topics you've sort of
delved into politics and everything that's going
on there and then you've delved into bitcoin so
i want to go back a little bit before we get into
black america and everything that's going on there
i want to understand a little bit about bitcoin
and how you landed on it what is it about bitcoin
that caught your attention oh man so i i think um
you know i lived through the 2008-2009 financial
crisis i was in college at the time um that really
piqued my interest with finances uh even though
i was you know more in the tech uh you know i was
in college so i was learning computer science but
that's what picked my financial interest
because how can an economy just fail like this
you know we're american what's going on um and
when you're in college you're already broke you go
from like broke to broken like jesus i'm working
i'm not going anywhere for like three months so
um that peaked my interest and then i was
introduced to bitcoin by a friend of 2013 um and
the best part about you know that introduction was
it came from the financial industry he worked for
uh uh i don't want to say the name but he worked
for a financial industry place yeah and um
they spoke about bitcoin but he didn't
understand it and since i was in the
uh computer world he was like you might understand
it better it's sort of this like techie thing so
you just pass it off to me um and i ran with it
i watched some videos from max kaiser i saw how
the winklevoss brothers you know how they were
invested uh and i think i came from it's two
ends of the spectrum i think people getting
bitcoin either so rich you can take a chance
or you're so poor you're like what
do i have to lose that's where i was
i was a teacher you know our teachers don't
really get they're notoriously underpaid
i was like what do i really have to lose let's see
what this bitcoin thing is and it started out as
i want to make money but because we had a bear
market um introduced me to the technology i was
like okay well i need to focus on this see it
and then the picture broadened up from there and
i think that's what really helped me i had two
almost three years where i didn't speak about
bitcoin which is funny because you know some
people two weeks and they're already experts
so yeah so it took some time but that was my
start and then uh getting to where we are today
yeah i think i think that's so interesting that
you make a really good point you know people are
either super rich that they can take that chance
um i think that was the winklevoss brothers that's
their story and then someone you know like herself
who's like well i i that's the only thing i can do
it just sort of it sort of makes sense so but what
was like that rebel moment whereby you thought
okay this is actually revolutionary was it i mean
did you even have one are we just sort of thinking
well you know we've had the financial crisis
anything will be better than than what we have now
um well when i started reading more financial
things and i started understanding um basically
how the federal reserve ran everything um
jekyll island reading that book um real that
really opened up my mind to the point where i
was saying well the system as a whole is built
for us to lose because of inflation it started
down that whole path and i was like if there
is a solution bitcoin would be it because it's a
scarce asset it's digital people can use it for
the future i got laughed out of the room so much
i actually use that as a that was the light bulb
moment was when i was telling people about it and
they were laughing and they were like what are you
talking about this is so to me an idea is not big
enough unless people are laughing at it at first
if everybody accepted it i'm sort of an outsider
i sort of i probably would have ran away from
well everybody's on it now i'm gonna do my own
thing um so because it was you know a time period
where people didn't understand it they kind of
laughing out the rooms or they didn't even want
to pursue it that that was a light bulb moment and
i think that happened it was an event in charlotte
2014 i went to it was a financial uh like urban
league or something like that a lot of black
professionals a lot of rich people and no i was
wearing this exact sweatshirt as a matter of fact
okay nobody knew what i was talking about nobody
gave me the time of day yeah most people were
like well that's cute it's a digital collectible
type thing so i think that was the light bulb i
was like i'm on to something because none of them
understand it and you know uh now here we are now
they're begging for bitcoin yeah i guess they sort
of thought it was like this weird nerdy tech thing
and it's just like sit back in your box you know
what kind of thing yeah and especially i mean i
know how i look black guy dressed kind of regular
they think of bitcoin it's like a nerdy white dude
in his mom's basement that's how it was um because
that's what they thought they were like isn't it
some techy nerdy thing in silicon valley yeah i
was like no it's for everybody but it started that
way so good i'm glad we was pretty user friendly
so then that's really interesting okay so you
said like it started off with this perception
of this nerdy white guy in his mom's basement
or whatever however you want to put it but then
when were you like hang on this could be good
for black america like at what point i don't
want to get into like we'll get into like the
problems that it could solve but at what point
did you make that kind of realization and that
connection and then with that in mind as well
do you think that the current financial system
do you think that it is how do i put this sort of
do you think it it's worse on the black community
than it is on the white community or do you think
it's just terrible as it is as a whole and you're
just there you know doing what you can do for your
own community uh well i like to use the quote as
far as economics go in america if america has a
cold black community has a flu and if there is a
problem of course it's there it affects everybody
but because of the systematic uh financial racism
discrimination whatever you want to call it all of
that has happened it's documented it's historical
many people have written about it um because that
has happened we have seen the numbers and you
uh you have a black community with less savings
uh less earned income things of that nature the
biggest thing for me was because this affects
us all of course bitcoins for everybody but i
targeted the black community for one family but
of course also community because if anybody can
understand uh something that threatens the status
quo and being misrepresented in the media like
bitcoin was should be the black community pretty
pretty common i mean we've seen welfare queens and
and lazy black man on every you know me on every
telecast media that we've seen we know this so
at what point do you decide what do we have
to lose let's let's try something different
that came for me uh around 2014 2015 um you know
sort of the ferguson riots happening and people
like what's the solution and i'm like you know i
don't really know but i know it has to start with
economics i mean everything you're talking about
you can march all you want we've done everything
i always like to tell people whenever
you're on many forums we've had a black
president we have black ceos we have black
millionaires we have like politicians we have
black people in power we still have the same basic
um median income as 1968. so what does that mean
economically nothing has been solved and i think
you start to see that i mean even with some of
the little i don't get to political start but
some of the political parties that have won
the presidency here some of the black groups
are trying to understand why they're just like
ah we don't need you now it's no more you don't
have any leverage there's no economic foundation
so once i saw that and i saw bitcoin was
there that to me was the ultimate answer
yeah that's really interesting because i you
know everything that's been going on this year
with blm there's been a lot of um significant
black people ice cube for example you know
talking about um you know it starts with um not so
much it's not necessarily money in itself but it
starts with kind of like a basic understanding
of business a basic understanding of economics
and how to as a community better to sort of you
know leverage this newfound knowledge and and then
move forward right um so with so so with how so
how do i explain this okay so how would you then
sort of put that forward though because i often
find that it's so hard just to get the average
person to tap into bitcoin and say okay this could
help but how do you get that message forward do
you think it's just a matter of you know we've
tried everything else what else have you got to
lose is that kind of the idea uh to an extent but
also education and leading by example uh i like to
tell people that my own family laughed at a lot
of the ideas i had with bitcoin until i moved to
beverly hills and then all of a sudden it was like
what's that bitcoin thing you're talking about
so i mean leading by example not just on the
money standpoint but just lifestyle change
seeing me start businesses a lot of networking uh
touring around the country being able to have a
network of people in a community to me that's so
uh close-knit uh bitcoin you really can't break
it up we started a currency from scratch i mean
that's never been done before so uh i think if you
leave by example and you show people this they'll
see that bitcoin is a better answer than what they
have and most people they don't even argue with
it anymore they're like all right we understand
it's going to be great um you know but how do i
get into it i think that argument is kind of over
um last the last boron we had a lot of people
who still questioned it was like the bubble pop
oh what are you going to do now i think anybody
who survived from 2017 to now wow before that um
should have any say so to tell somebody like look
this is not going away and uh if somebody's on the
fence in my opinion i'm starting to go the satoshi
route if you don't get it by now i don't have time
to explain he said that 10 years ago i'm saying
in 2020 only because there's no way you haven't
heard of it if you want to learn then learn
but if you just like nice it still won't work
kind of now you're getting left out of the
room it's so funny because i'm producing like
a lot of content daily and i'm on tick tock and
people talk about crypto twitter being absolutely
hectic and toxic and mental but i've got to say
crypto tick tock is mental i get people daily
call you know saying bitcoin is a scam that's a
ponzi scheme so i'm going on a rabbit hole and
i probably shouldn't yeah no i know but it's so
funny because like we often say oh come on i think
everybody sort of knows at this point that it's
not a scam but there are still people out there
that really believe this thing is just the biggest
load of rubbish but i want to go back a little bit
and understand a bit more about you and your
experience and because i think you know for
you to make that connection between bitcoin and
black america you've obviously had to have some
kind of experience which made you feel like okay
we need something so i'd like to just go into your
background a bit and know a bit more about issues
that you face and how you think okay you know what
maybe it could be different uh so in theory um
before 2017 in theory i always thought to myself
group economics works because in larger cities
uh you have chinatown yeah koreatown you have
a little ethiopia you have these economic
communities that help each other live each other
up and because they're insulated they don't have
as many uh of the social problems like you might
see what police or we might see with politicians
we don't really own that in the black community
a lot of uh our stores are owned by uh people
outside of our community a lot of our money goes
to outside of our community so group economics
was something in theory i thought of in 2017 when
i moved to la in 2017 i saw it in real life and
i was like this works i mean i'm walking through
koreatown and half the stores are in korean they
don't even care that you can't read what the store
says because their group economics works they hire
their kids their kids working in the stores they
send them to college they become the doctors that
they use later it's it's it works so it you know
in practice what i said was well in my opinion
it's still sort of bad in this current system
with bitcoin though that value uh increases over
time so we can practice group economics combine
it with bitcoin blockchain technology as the
basis that to me would solve most of our problems
and i ran with it that's why i wrote
the first book big one in black america
saw what happened after covet and decided to write
the second book bitcoin black america the second
edition which is alpha pre-order now so the reason
i did all of that was because of that premonition
i was like what do we what are we even talking
about like if we're gonna do something that works
in our community group economics has proven to
work solo millionaires and a couple billionaires
doesn't mean anything oprah will smith and lebron
can't be representation for those that's not what
it's like so uh it has to be sort of a group
effort because it works and we have a global
community and i think we should take a shot at
it bitcoin is probably the easiest one yeah what
i think is actually really cool is that bitcoin
is so much more than just like an investment or a
currency there's a kind of mentality that
comes with it so i feel like if you're going
to implement bitcoin in this community and you're
going to push for it you're sort of adding more
whether it be like the idea of taking personal
responsibility not relying on the government
um and sort of just i guess it also brings like
a mentality of like innovation um and just tech
in general and tech is the future so it's like um
it's more than just bitcoin isn't it it's a home
it's really a rabbit hole for real because what
you find out when you learn about bitcoin is
okay well what's this cryptography stuff okay
well what's this algorithm okay well what's the
math you have to do okay what's the history
of money what's the history of governments
all of a sudden you're learning things that make
you more independent then you start changing
your mindset on how things work because when you
actually have free money what ends up happening
is people understand they're not connected to
the state anymore they're a sovereign citizen
that opens up more i know people that have
gotten into bitcoin also they're like i should
start growing my own food now i should probably
find a water supply i should probably figure
out ways that i can uh learn about how to build
things because i may have to build my own houses
all these things that leads you down this road
and it's inevitable it just takes some time
yeah and i as well as that you know it's what
kind of gets me though is i'm always trying to
figure out the best way to explain it to people
right because bitcoin's not always going to be
twenty four thousand dollars we're always going
to be in a ball run um you know and actually
my mum today brought bought some bitcoin um so
i was also very exciting but she really was you
know really yeah exactly it's all very exciting
um but she's only really sort of extra sold and
my brother's extra sold simply because we're in
a bull market so what do you think some of the
biggest issues are going to be when convincing
black america that bitcoin could actually
be of value to them um so two main things for
people who have a uh a low time preference
meaning that they're in this for the long term
then unless you bought bitcoin uh this past week
zero people have lost money everybody's in profit
so the volatility aspect of it is if you just wait
i mean it's so simple it's complex it's just about
a big point in weight everybody's because the
market's built that way and the value comes from a
strong network of holders who will never sell and
that is happening now second thing i would say
is for detractors who say okay i don't really
like bitcoin i don't want to use it you
know um or they just don't understand it
one of the things you have to let happen is you
have to let them lose money and i know that's
harsh but let them buy the top let them see a bear
market for three years and then come back again
and then they see nothing happen because
people who bought in 2017 or 17 000
are like oh well that's over you know what i mean
but they were dying inside for three years i've
seen it this is the third time i've seen it so
in my opinion just let it happen and to me losing
money is the best teacher you gotta pay tuition at
some point so if you think you're just a lone wolf
who's gonna solve the market by yourself you don't
want any help go ahead and do that but i know how
many people have lost thousands of dollars doing
that and some people when they they need that so
that's both ties to the point i want to talk a
lot about victim mentality because i feel like
it's something which the bitcoin community tends
to sort of reject just because generally speaking
obviously um you know just because it's all
about like you know not your keys not your
coins take personal responsibility everyone seems
to be a bit of a libertarian to some extent um
so when i was um like reading and researching
about your book and everything um one of the
biggest things which kind of got me was you know
how do we pull people out though like how do we
pull people out of a victim mentality because
a lot of the time whatever community it comes
from you know whether whether it's just any old
person that's gone through a difficult you know
life difficult life circumstances it's really hard
to pull people out um so do you think do you you
know i know you're obviously on your second
edition of the book but how possible is it
um to sort of give somebody a solution because you
know there's like they say you can give somebody
um a bit you can get you know give someone a
fish and they eat the day or teach someone how
to fish and then they eat the rest of their life
so how likely are you to be able to actually like
help them and really sort of i don't know wake
people up and bring them out of that kind of
fatality well i start where my dad started with me
he told me when i was young he's like nobody owes
you anything and nobody's gonna help you so if you
start there you don't you don't some people don't
agree with that though like we've we say that
again and again and some people are still like no
the government does owe me something nobody's he's
especially weird especially as a man like when he
told me that it hit me because i was so young and
i was like what do you mean y'all help me all the
time you know me like my mom but as i got older
you realize it's if you can't help yourself uh
at some point you're always gonna be begging out
for help from somebody else and i hate the victim
mentality especially in my community when it comes
to things that in my opinion can be solved if you
work at it but most people don't want to do work
that's that's the only problem uh to me if there's
a solution that can be had for different issues if
we can get a solution we should work towards that
but if you're gonna go and complain and say
hey please please help us please help us
to me that's that's uh very weak and those
discussions are not uh things i want to take
part of so yeah i'm not a big fan of the victim
mentality some of the things that's been happening
too uh with a lot of social media is that it's
actually like popular to be a victim everybody
that gets something done to him is like oh my
god the worst thing ever and sometimes i point
out things that's happened to me but that's not
gonna stop me i can't look my children in the
face and or my daughter in the face and future
children or my wife and say oh man i could we
couldn't be successful because the person out
there stopped me like that's that's so weak to
me and really as uh as somebody who's growing up
in a family of entrepreneurs or people who stood
on their own i think that's kind of where it came
from even from my grandfather owned his own bar
uh you know my father owns an insurance company
you know people have their own businesses my
cousins have uh clothing lines you know we've all
been like you have to be able to hold yourself up
now we're all strong so when i talk about the
community or us being strong as a community
help everybody by helping yourself everybody wants
this we all come together let's help each other so
nothing will happen to us but if you're not strong
yourself uh what exactly can you contribute so
not having a victim mentality just
taking life head on living i mean
you only get one i'm not gonna sit around and cry
because something happened like it's it's just
yeah i get through it and you will have obstacles
just deal with it yeah i totally respect that
and i wish more people had that mentality um i i
absolutely wish because you either find you know
either you go through something really difficult
in life and then you're sort of like okay well i
don't have a choice either i can sulk or i
can pull myself up um or people just don't
pull themselves up and i wonder um i wonder to
what extent people can pull themselves up right
all i'm gonna say is in this in this day and age
with the internet everybody has a phone everybody
has access to information it may take some time
but everybody can at least pull themselves up to
an extent i'm not saying everybody can become
a millionaire but you can go middle class if
you get a skill learn it over time you may have
to eat ramen for too much straight like i did
i mean i did that a few times training bitcoin you
may have to not go out you may have to uh tighten
your budget up a little bit you may have to sit
and focus and read for long periods of time things
people don't want to do what i'm saying is there
is a way out but if it's harder than others i'm
not about to say oh it's harder so i'm not gonna
do it you just have to do it um and i think once
people understand that and they find ways like
with big point crypto to assist with with that
mindset i think it's a win-win so once we get that
monster uh a lot of us already do is just a few
that don't the few that do have the victim mindset
they're the loudest so that's why you're here yeah
i mean i i just think it's such a shame because
i share the exact same mentality as you i think
absolutely okay i wouldn't have to be millionaires
but i think absolutely anybody can pull themselves
up from any situation i've seen too many
incredibly successful people come from absolutely
terrible circumstances and i don't believe that
it's entirely luck like i just don't i think luck
is just a by-product of preparation um so i mean
this is kind of a really interesting conversation
because it goes beyond um bitcoin right because
it's all about you know improving yourself like
you said there's enough information out there
everybody's got a phone everybody's good internet
um i'm just wondering how we really sort of like
push that message home because especially to the
people who don't really understand about bitcoin
i'm just sort of figure trying to figure out like
how you know how like how that continues to go how
that looks in the next 10 years um i don't know if
you have like 10-year kind of vision or anything
like that i mean this for generational stuff
the bitcoin i own i think i'll just be passing
down um i had to you know 10 years out uh 2030
i would say bitcoin will be the reserve asset of
major corporations if not a country at that point
we're already saying michael st larry's
about one and a half billion worth of bitcoin
that is just the beginning trust me he's gonna
look like the smartest man in the room next
year and a bunch of ceos that do not want to
look back they're gonna do the same thing so
i think we'll see that we'll see it more
uh as a store value for large corporations
then we'll see maybe the stable coin wars take
off on top of that because of course china has
their own others are building um so 10 years out
i think we'll see a very a very different monetary
system and i think a lot of people will build
on top of bitcoin because it will be the longest
and strongest um but other all coins will succeed
the same way companies succeed whenever anything
happens so uh i think man this there's so much
d5 is going on now we have nfts who knows what
will be ten years from now i just can't wait
for that you know nine to ten year old that's
that 10 years from now it's probably going to be
the mark zuckerberg or whoever oh that's crazy
okay you don't mean like creates an incredible
product so um that's what i'm looking forward to
that's also why i'm doing a bitcoin summer camp
to teach kids trying to get that pipeline because
this is the future and i can't wait i mean
hopefully we have some ai in there somewhere
with uh with the crypto world still young but yeah
i think that's what we'll see ten years from now
yeah i think i think it's insane to think
that you know we could actually see a
well i don't know i see when we talk about like
bitcoin as a as a as a global reserve currency
i'm always really just like unsure you know when
to work scalability and this and that like as a
store of value i'm on board i'm there um as like
this global reserve currency i just don't know
but what i'm doing it could be like four
or five countries to start using it um
but what i but what i do think i i definitely
think you know we are going down that route um you
know no more cat you know there will be a cash for
society um unfortunately for some um yeah we are
you know i always say everything has gone digital
right you know i say like dating has gone digital
socializing has gone digital and the way that
we work is digital the way we eat it's digital
everything is just digital so for me it's just
inevitable that everything's going to go that way
um but what do you think you know like there's
a lot of talk about bitcoin being this political
thing and people say it's apolitical but i'm
really on the side of my is political now i get
why they say it's a political because it's like
you opt out right but i feel like opting out is a
political choice exactly i do too and you know as
part of the political process i don't participate
in these games this is a circus whatever they try
to sell to people as far as these groups i don't
join groups i'm an individual i have things i like
about certain ones and then you can ask me that's
about it that's about as political as i get but
bitcoin being political is very political i mean
yeah i don't know if people who know this but the
day my first book came out president trump tweeted
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies are not real currency
you should not use it blah blah blah oh really
uh it was uh july 11th uh 2019. uh it's i write
about it i write about it in the second book
because it was crazy no time before or after
that did he tweet about it other than the day
my book came out so is bitcoin political i think
it has entered the political market i think some
of the regulations or regulators who are trying
to uh make a bridge with bitcoin uh have family
members on themselves who own it so it is getting
into politics and what we're starting to see is
the 25 30 year old who's been in bitcoin for a
few years when they become the next politicians
they're going to work towards bitcoin being a part
of our our nation so i think it is political i
think it has entered the political sphere i think
when people talk about joe biden's second biggest
donor uh owning a crypto exchange in china i mean
that you can't ignore that i mean you gotta ignore
that can you yeah it's kind of factual so bitcoin
is intertwined somehow the biggest thing is uh
nobody talks about it publicly not the big big
names um but i think it is intertwined somehow
and it will be a race uh for mining there will be
a race of course for big one to store value and
then whoever has the best cbdc that that's kind of
the nationalistic approach to money moving faster
i want to talk a bit more about a book because
for those watching that don't know i haven't read
it yet so i plan to read it over the christmas
holidays these are my my well my plans drawing
locked down because things are just absolutely
terrible here um so tell me about some like the
biggest challenges that you face writing this
book because how did you did you sort of break
down all the issues that you've experienced and
all the issues that you perceive to be um you know
relevant in black america and sort of talk about
how bitcoin can solve those take me through it how
does the book look absolutely so um the first
book i start off sort of uh memoir style just
telling my story so that people can understand who
the writer is uh that i am a regular guy who took
the time to learn about something interesting
and used it to create you know what i do now um
and i think that story kind of opens eyes because
they realize oh you don't have to be a millionaire
to be successful you don't have to be you know
some you know kid who got fifty thousand dollars
and just having to become a millionaire you can
work your way up there's strategies for that so
it starts there it talks about um the digital
economy introduces how bitcoin can start sort
of a circular economy if you buy uh or invest
in small businesses whether black hole did not i
started with black owned in the book because i
want to understand that's the backbone of any
strong economy small business and in our community
if we use bitcoin you can sort of opt out
of the current market so i go to that point i talk
about things such as bitcoin and the black church
how we can use it as non-profit donations as
a store of value um talk about how athletes
sense black athletes uh in the nba nfl and uh and
hip-hop have a lot of control of social currency
if they adopt bitcoin if they talk about
cryptocurrency in the black community that could
be good for us as far as adoption yeah so i'll go
into all of all of that in the book talk about how
in other countries it could be adopted but um
you know in the second book i take it up a notch
way more information but yeah those are
some of the ways i also talk about banks
i have a chapter called book the fans
uh but in the second version it's called
yeah so and it's funny i actually did a talk
with a bank and that was one of the guy's
favorite chapters so that goes through all of the
racial discrimination just in the past eight years
so it's not like something in the i talk about
redlining i talk about racial discrimination with
loans i talk about all that but i'm talking about
stuff that happened like eight years ago or three
years ago so they're having to do settlements for
that for uh black and brown people unfortunately
so we don't owe them anything and that's sort of
my argument with moving into the bitcoin market so
uh that's what the book is about second book
has uh more information if i can run through
that real quick yeah go for it yeah yeah i mean
uh it talks about bitcoin and black america tour
how things have progressed in the economy with you
know covid and the federal stimulus uh bitcoins
price movements talks about privacy how to set
up a truly private wallet because a lot of people
it's not enough now to just buy bitcoin you need
to have node which i'll talk about and describe
in there and you also need to have a completely
private wallet which i also described as well
i'll talk about bitcoin in marriage but that's
which i think is a pretty spicy chapter because
of marriage what did you say bitcoin in marriage
yes what is that what is that nobody understands
that when you go to court now if you own bitcoin
cryptocurrency if you get a divorce you have to
you have to yeah you have to understand those
laws and regulations or just getting half your
wallet exactly because i've actually had
to consult judges where that's come up in
court and they have no clue what they were saying
they were like crypto i don't even know so i talk
about that also discuss how if you are married
long term if you pass away you want to be your
partner to know how to access your private keys
you don't just want your people to go away also
return to wealth is built by being able to hold
it so if you're not able to hold bitcoin for the
next hundred years what are you really doing so i
talk about that um uh the laws in different states
i talked about uh bitcoin as reparations uh i
thought i discussed yeah wait i wanna i wanna just
i was asked the topic i wanted to actually talk to
you bitcoin as reparations yes how does that work
uh so without going too much in the chapter the
basic premise is uh i don't believe reparations
are ever going to be given to black people uh in
the trillions of what they say that's not going to
happen do you want do you believe that you guys
should get reparations firstly i argue i argue
that because reparations have been given out in
this country two people who were disenfranchised
black people are owed preparations there is a
precedent for what we're asking for the problem is
if you're asking for it to happen there's two main
things that i discussed first of all the printing
of money print trillions of dollars debases the
currency get gets rid of the value you think
you just gave everybody the second thing is you
can either ask for reparations or you can take
them and in my opinion most of the corporations or
banks or whoever that disenfranchise our community
have not purchased bitcoin or are interested
in purchasing bitcoin if you can buy an asset
that they are interested in creating a market
value you can give yourself preparations
and i to go through all of how that could be
possible and not just with the value of bitcoin
but business enterprise blockchain technology
all of that using that to your advantage in order
to get what you feel is owed to you because
i'm just going to jump in just so i can like
fully understand what you're getting at so you
don't believe reparations will ever be given so
you're looking at bitcoin as a way for people
to sort of take their own reparations because
you're buying bitcoin before the people who um
you know you would hold accountable were able
to buy them um buy the bitcoins and plus it's a
deflationary asset so it's likely to go up anyways
you're going to get paid back in that way so
it's kind of like the reparations which you never
were going to get basically is that the way you
look at it yeah exactly and the money that was
put into the country to build it one thing i
also want to say to you i don't necessarily
think we won't get it i just think that
the work it takes to get to that point
uh is a waste of time and what are we waiting for
i'm tired of people going to capitol hill trying
to see what more what more information do you need
i mean there is no more real explanation you need
and i know people are working on that
i would encourage them to keep going
but that's not my that's not how i do things i'm
sort of impatient i guess but there's a reason for
that there there's a time stamp on when you can
take advantage of something that is life-changing
and revolutionary stop asking for reparations
let's focus on getting in the bitcoin market
or building a economy where we own it because
the value you think that uh you're owed will be
given right back to you because value is given
to whoever creates it and if we're in the value
market that it's ultimately going to happen so
i believe in taking back what you think is yours
not asking it and i'd rather ask for forgiveness
than permission any day yeah i think that's really
cool honestly like i just i'm i'm like huge
respect i just think we're doing is amazing
i think just because i just inherently despise
everything victim mentality related i love how
you're just there just sort of like guys this
this is it like here's your answer like please
you know you're just there trying to educate
people but you know in terms of mass adoption
then um to what extent do you um see bitcoin being
integrated into people's lives because you talk
about that integration you know you spoke about
church but to what extent is this even possible
uh so i think one of the best ways to intertwine
this in people's life is the advent of cash back
rewards in the form of bitcoin and one of my main
premises when i talk to people is meet them where
they are so basically you do what you already
do and you can earn bitcoin if you understand
that long term this is an asset you want to hold
so you have services not just feel anything big
or whatnot but like fold out simple things
you can spend the wheel on fold out you get
free satoshis for that there's i mean it takes
three seconds um you can purchase goods on lolly
you can i mean every time i post face post mates i
get three and a half percent back in bitcoins free
money for what i already do meeting with people
that have cash app already i usually explain to
them hey you already have cash up the boost thing
just came about but i mean you could have bought
it in there and you know it's it's a no-brainer to
me even uh services like black fire i mean to me
it's kind of a no-brainer that instead of selling
your crypto because that is a taxable event you
can actually put it up as collateral get a cash
loan which i actually have just talked to a cpa
and you can actually write off if you do it as a
business the um the interest rates that you pay uh
for your business so that's these are things
that people do anyway it's just like just doing
a bitcoin because it's a more profitable market
so meet people where they are help them basically
establish uh you know the mindset that bitcoin
is for everybody and once they start to see that
they're like okay it's not for the rich is rich
and you can't buy a fraction of a bitcoin i mean
that was the biggest question for probably three
years people didn't work by practicing like man
i don't have ten thousand or twenty thousand
even now even now people still say that and
uh once people realize that just meet them
where they are and uh i think you'll have good
success there i think people get too caught up i
think people are so smart they get caught up in
explaining the hash rate and the in smart
contracts nobody needs to know that sometimes
nobody cares about electrical elliptic
curves dude nobody cares talk to them
what about any other old coins then like do you
see any other alts as number one a good store of
value and number two because at the end of the
day i guess you know you can't you're not gonna
be teaching everybody to trade that's just you
know it's kind of just like buy bitcoin and wait
that's good enough um but yeah do you see anything
which could be just as a valuable um like ethereum
perhaps or um well view uh the all coin market uh
sort of like i view uh bitcoin early on as far as
utility now bitcoin i think it stands alone by
itself because it's an anonymous creator you can't
confiscate it that is hard money that is
reserved asset but i think of all coins
sort of as companies or as projects that are
using a token uh that can become valuable
for certain things so ethereum they have what i
feel like is a novel approach to try and create
decentralized apps i know all the attack vectors
i know security problems i know what's wrong with
ethereum you know changing the ethereum classic uh
there's something like that with every coin we saw
xrp today uh the sec may be coming out to them
every single point that's not bitcoin this can
happen to but from a purely company standpoint
just trying to innovate in the blockchain space
i like a few projects i mean it's fun it's
fun to have metamask in in your browser and
be able to buy nfts it's good that you can build
you know smart contracts do you own any nfts
exactly i'm sorry do you own any nfts uh no i do
not own any nfts i bought them for other people
but i don't know um i have worked or started
working with uh somebody named micah johnson his
nft just sold 420 000. uh i'm trying to put on an
nft show like a museum type show on crypto boxes
so things like that are interesting and i think
when we talk about the gamification of the crypto
world i think all coins are better for kids
because if there's no like if you're not giving
them millions of dollars with it oh you give them
20 bucks it's good for them to play around with
use the blockchains are faster because they're
not cluttered um a lot of times they have you know
things like uh uh like narrow ring signatures some
people may like privacy those features like that i
think work well but again none of them are bitcoin
to me because it's unconflictable everything else
i think has that chance but we'll see and you are
the co-host of the gentleman of crypto so i want
to know a little bit more about this um what do
you guys talk about how where did this come from
oh yeah so we're at episode 627 that's crazy it
just felt weird 600 yeah yeah so we've been doing
the general crypto pretty much every day for the
last three years okay we started in 2017 and after
we would have started 2016 but we were like did
people even people even tune in who knows so we
just went for it uh me and my uh my co-host king
um we were one of the first crypto shows that had
live every day i think we definitely wanted the
longest running not sure but we had a live show
every day we talk about news and updates and
we answer any questions that come in live and
we've been doing this since 2017. um one of the
biggest aspects of it is it's not a huge show we
only have 4 000 subscribers but everybody sticks
with like a close-knit community because again to
me long-term these are people who probably don't
use for networking for the rest of our life who
cares if you have to do a 30 minute or hour-long
free show when you get to network with people who
can help build for the future so we decided to do
that a lot of opportunities came out of that and
uh fortunately you know it's opened up doors that
i didn't think would happen because i had never
made a youtube video before 2017. that's one
thing people don't know i'm on interviews now
and talk a lot now but i just was anti-video for a
long time in the bitcoin world because i was like
if people want to learn just go online but then
i realized we need it no we need it people need
to hear you talking they need to see your face
and this is a real person behind you or behind
it and uh it's work so far again like i said not
a huge show but i think we get great information
so with all of this in mind you've got
your books and everything that you've done
where's your family at with all of this have
you managed to sort of get them to buy bitcoin
uh yeah i mean it's it's
like 100 approval right now
but first it was scary you know i would have
plans about maybe we could you know put you
know our money together about bitcoin back in the
day uh yeah i could show you individually yeah
i had all these ideas and they were just like
no there's nothing that convinces us uh until
you know recently so now of course everybody in my
family pretty much either owns bitcoin or is is in
the process of doing it nobody even questions it
anymore i do have friends who are still on the
fence yeah the only reason being on the fence
is because the price is so high unfortunately
i told them when the price was probably i think
600 or 500 you know a long time ago but oh you
told them then and they didn't i also gave a
lot of bitcoin away back in the day i remember
when i first started when bitcoin was around 200
so i would give i was giving away 0.1 bitcoin like
it was nothing because to me i was like that's 20
bucks and you can get started you can do something
i don't know how much bitcoin i gave away
back wait how are you where were you buying
it from back then well back then i was i was
getting it uh actually through local bitcoins
yep and it was the easiest way for me you could
meet up meet people by large amounts that was
the easiest way then through an exchange i had
coinbase for about six months i would say back
in 2015 but got rid of them don't use them anymore
uh what happens i think that's everybody if you
know a lot of bitcoin is they dunk on bitcoin for
good uh they don't hold coinbase for good reason
um not reliable to me but yeah and now i'm mostly
uh swan it's one bitcoin lowest fees in the uh in
the market so i like to use them but yeah i mean
now i don't buy much anymore i just kind of sit on
it but yeah it was it was a crazy time back then
and what if someone like so you said that you know
it's the price being let's say you just call it
24k whatever that your friends are just like oh
it's too expensive but what are the other things
like are they really do they really get it like
do they sort of see it as like a cult and you know
something that they want to get involved in that's
the thing like okay people have seen me or read
my books they're like i get it i know it works
but i just don't know it's an anonymous creator
and you're like wasn't going to do anything
i was like that's keeping you from whatever
like you know i heard this i read the story
that bitcoin got hacked and i was like no somebody
got hacked their bitcoin got stolen would you stop
using cash for bank got robbed no so what are
you talking about so they still have these like
these these premonitions or intuitions i
would say that something bad is gonna happen
because the biggest one i get now is
so is the government gonna shut it down
and i'll send them the link where they literally
the office of comptroller the currency said
we're not shutting down bitcoin we are not
i'll send them that link and they'll still say
but still do you think they could and i'm
like i don't understand you know exactly
where these questions come from but it's just
people get scared not having the knowledge
when they see that you can own and plus not being
used to being free like some people they're scared
shitless what they think about the fact that i get
to own my own i get to do this myself it's me they
don't even want that so you have to understand
that too this is the first time ever unless you're
113 years old uh or 106 years old you you haven't
lived during the time without the federal reserve
so you don't even know what it's like to live
in a system that's free enough where you can
just enter it start today and then money is money
well this is what i was getting at earlier when i
was talking about victim mentality because people
sort of just don't want that responsibility like
they don't you know um because it's scary
because it's not just like it's not just
a private key it's like the sea prairies as well
and then it's like where do i put it and then like
you know you you put it on ledger then your
database gets hacked you know so like it's
it's kind of like a a real fear and i think
the most interesting thing for me about bitcoin
is like i obviously think it's political but
it's a mentality so much and i just i just think
that's gonna be one of the real struggles when
it comes to mass adoption because well it depends
what kind of mass adoption we see because
you know if you start having everything in
in custody with custodians then it's different
but right now you know you're trying to get
people in and sort of teach them about freedom
i don't think people want freedom to be honest
yeah some people don't even want to be free that's
the funniest part about this whole situation is
you say it as if that's something everybody wants
and some people like nope i would much rather have
such and such let them do it which is fine which
is you know some of the uh backlash a lot of
bitcoin people get is oh why would you suggest
products with a third party and like you do
understand there's a population of people that are
never going to be self-custody or self-sovereign
and you know let people figure it out but again
i don't really like to cuddle adults that's why
i like teaching kids because i would rather show
them really but adults you get one chance with
me if you don't get it i'm i don't care what big
one for me i love strength yeah i love teaching
people or helping people that want to be helped i
don't think i don't there's no debating or going
back and forth um you know you have your opinion
just go with it if you really have that conviction
then and then go with it because i really i really
believe what i'm doing so you better believe what
you're talking about because i've been there yeah
i'm with you this kind of just like it all links
back to the same thing because it just reminds me
i was trying to help a friend the other day with
her work and i was trying to sort of be like you
know you really need to use social media leverage
it like this like for me i think tik tok is
just like an incredible innovation for um online
creators and i was trying to really help her
and she was like i'll do it tomorrow i'll do it
tomorrow and she didn't and then last day i'm done
no more you're not a child like i'm not coddling
adults as you said yeah exactly you know you know
i told you that's all that matters you can't never
ever say i didn't tell you but the only complaints
i really had are people saying why don't you tell
me about more so if you have any reservations
that's really the only complaint i really ever had
yeah 100 and just finally i saw you tweeting today
um about the xrp news i just wanted to get your
thoughts on it you don't have to throw yourself in
a fire so you're you're welcome to sort of say no
i'm not going to comment too much we'll go for
it if you have any thoughts yeah let's say the
xrp buy are we going to get it well i think it's
sort of a non-starter because they front ran the
news by saying the sec is going to do this yeah
let's go to the front running uh which i guess
was smart on their part just to sort of beat it
to the punch uh one thing i've said since 2018
actually to get earlier than that is that at
any point xrp could be considered a security
and it's over i mean what happens is if they make
the claim that it's a security they can go back
and forth they can argue the highway test they can
say they need to be new standards doesn't matter
i think exchanges won't take the risk they'll
just de-list xrp and then what happens then now
he's gone and to me i don't see a real use
case i know it's pre-mined i know there's a
people that hold it it's not for me but for
speculative traders do you thing i don't i don't
really stop anybody from anything that they want
to do but i do if i consult people tell them that
that's not for me so this news is sort of hyping
people up but i'm just trying to remind people
that yeah this could happen um at any time and
especially we've seen that in ico market they were
smacking the ico market in 2019 and this year so
yeah it could happen um he's going to be careful
yeah i think um you make an interesting point i
mean brad garland house was the one to come out
straight away um and blow the lid off the story
and sort of just say okay we're getting sued
um but it'll be interesting to see what happens
i mean i i i tweeted today that i i do feel sorry
for those holding xrp but those holding xrp
you think this is great so that's also cool
um i mean some of them were saying if we get
through this the price will really go to the
moon because it'll be and i'm like all right i
understand that's you know that's fomo that's
emotion but just looking at data metrics not
something that i i tend to uh pay attention to
yeah i'm with you okay so just finally then tell
us what are your last words where can people find
you somebody has actually put in the comments can
you leave a link to the book so send me a link
afterwards or you can put the link in there in
the comments so where can people find you uh yeah
so uh you can find me on twitter at bitcoinsay
you can find me on instagram at bitcoins a llc
you can find me at bitcoinblackamerica.com and
uh if you reach out there uh the book bitcoin
of black america and the second edition
are available uh so working on that now
and uh the gentleman of crypto on youtube
monday through friday at 10 a.m eastern
well i want to thank you so much for coming
on i think what you're doing is absolutely
incredible it's right up my street i hate victim
mentality and i really think education knowledge
understanding um is everything people need i think
you know everything sort of starts and ends at the
education system i think the education system is
so broken it doesn't teach you entrepreneurship
um so the fact that you're pushing that to
help your own community i think is fantastic i
absolutely love it so thank you so much
for joining me today thank you for having
me glad to be here guys don't forget to tune
in next thursday 12 p.m est we'll see you then